-Welcome back,
and thank you for being here.
How many times
have you been on our show?
-I think it's like
third or fourth.
We're like family now.
-Yeah, exactly.
-As a kid, I always wanted to be
in The Roots, too,
so it just makes me feel closer
to one of my favorite
rap groups.
-Perfect.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Thanks for being here.
-Thanks for having me, man.
-You know,
I know you as Killer Mike
the performer, the artist,
but, also, I never saw
Killer Mike the actor.
And then I watched "Ozark,"
last season of "Ozark,"
and you crushed it, bud.
-Man, drug-dealing, white,
middle-class family --
this is my kind of show.
-How did you get
involved with "Ozark"?
-I loved that show like my old,
white boss loved "The Wire."
You know, he thought
I was from Baltimore.
So, I was like, "I don't even
have the same accent."
"But you sold drugs, Michael."
I met Laura Linney on a plane.
I was stoned.
I was high and high.
And my wife, Shana, used to love
watching "The Big C,"
so of course I couldn't pass up
a chance to be like,
"My wife loves you."
-Yeah.
-And she was
just incredibly nice.
So, someone on the show
besides her, the director,
who's an
amazing female director,
called over Jad,
my guy at WME, and say,
"Hey, would Mike
be interested in this?"
I read the part,
cried tears of joy
that I got to talk about
"Illmatic" on "Ozark."
And, man, it just was
a great experience.
-You crushed it.
-I want to be on TV more.
-Yeah. I love that you were
high and high.
So funny. That's a great line.
You know,
I wanted to ask you about this.
Midterm elections coming up.
I know you're an activist.
Is there a message you'd
like to get out there
to people about
the midterm elections?
-Yeah, get registered to vote.
Get out and vote.
It's very serious
and hyper-serious locally.
On a very local level,
the people that are
your chief of police,
the mayors you elect,
your prosecutors,
your city-council people.
It's very important.
A couple weeks ago,
they were threatening
the nightlife in Georgia,
in Atlanta in particular,
which kind of sprouts
some of the biggest artists
in the world, from 2 Chainz
to T.I. to Lil Baby to myself.
And if those clubs,
which a lot are independently
or small-business owned,
get closed,
then that closes
the whole economy.
I got a chance to
go testify with
a lot of other people
who own the clubs.
2 Chainz was there.
And because we did that,
city council
decided to work with
the club owners
to figure out better policy.
That's the power of voting
and that's why
I want people to vote.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Get out there.
Can we talk about "Run"?
-"Run."
It's my first single
in 10 years.
I'm in a very successful rap
group called Run the Jewels.
-Run the Jewels!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Shouts out to El-P,
my guy who's out on Fire Island
doing what ballin' rappers do,
as I'm sitting
here dancing and singing.
-[ Laughs ]
-And in 10 years,
it felt good to finally say,
"Okay, we take a pause."
COVID said, "Hold on.
Mike, why don't you give
the world a single?"
And I did it,
and people are responding well.
And it's a hopeful, uplifting,
from Black Atlanta,
Black America, just to say,
"We got to keep running
toward victory and freedom."
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And last week,
Governor Newsom signed
the Decriminalizing Artistic
Expression Act in California.
-Yeah.
-Can you talk about
how important that is?
-So, I'll give you this
really quickly.
There was this really -- She was
an old white lady, right?
She wrote an article called
"How to Kill Your Husband"
and then she went
and killed her husband.
And after she killed the guy,
the judge said,
"Well, you can't use the article
she wrote about it,"
because that's a part of her
artistic expression
and her First Amendment rights.
Well, a lot of kids
who are poor and in cities
didn't get the same -- or don't
get the same fair treatment.
They could say
something haphazardly
and they could be charged or it
could be added to a charge.
Governor Newsom
and the state of New York --
Assemblymen in California and a
senator, I believe, in New York
both have sponsored bills
to limit
the law's ability to do that,
because, ultimately,
the Constitution was written
for all of our benefit.
It took the
14th and 15th amendment
to recognize the
rights of African-Americans,
but if any of these rights
are infringed upon,
it will certainly infringe upon
all of us one day.
So I encourage people
to make sure
that you're strict about making
sure your Constitutional rights
are protected and covered.
And if you don't believe in
freedom of speech
for those people
you don't agree with,
you don't believe in
freedom of speech at all.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Because, for instance,
you are Killer Mike.
-Yes, yeah.
-But that's not because
you kill people.
-Microphones I slaughter.
-Yeah, okay, yeah.
Exactly. Just so you know,
that's exactly kind of
one of the points.
I want to say also, by the way,
thank you for doing this.
Your new single, "Run," is out,
and you put it out on cassette.
-Yes.
-That is money.
That is money right there.
Why did you do it on cassette?
-So, I've got to shout out
this collector from Atlanta
named Nuface,
who has cassettes, wax,
every piece of hip-hop toys.
And he's an amazing
hip-hop historian.
Partly because of people
like him that are out there,
it's value, and I just got
a bunch of old cars.
And my old cars
got CDs and cassettes,
and I like to jam it like
I jammed Raekwon's tape
back in the day.
-That's -- come on.
That's what I'm talking about!
Killer Mike, everybody.
Going to perform "Run" for us
after the break.
Come on back, everybody.